une mobilisation maximale c'est ce
qu'avait demandé l'intersyndicale pour
faire reculer l'exécutif
résultat la cgt a recensé 1,3 millions
de manifestants tandis que le ministère
de l'intérieur parle de 249 mille
personnes dans tout l'hexagone
des chiffres qui ont réjoui députés
représentants syndicaux et hommes de loi
j'ai remonté toute la manifestation et
qu' elle était presque à concorde que la
queue de la manifestation les quantités
à quoi était toujours à république en
compte et c'est énorme
je crois que c'est une des plus grosses
de depuis le début du mouvement donc le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
gens reste combatif mobilisé et ce que
je constate c'est que de plus en plus de
jeunes et de plus en plus de secteurs en
lutte
voilà gouvernement est pas au bout de
ses peines la validation du projet
annoncé par agnès buzyn ont sorti de
conseil des ministres n'a fait
qu'attiser la colère des syndicats
ces derniers ont annoncé que les grèves
continuerait avec déjà deux nouvelles
dates prévues à noter que
l'intersyndicale s'est réunie ce matin
et qu'on annonce déjà à moins que et des
inflexions du gouvernement que la
semaine prochaine il ya trois nouvelles
journées de mobilisation avec un temps
fort le 29 donc et vous le savez il ya
eu il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de
grévistes
vous parlez beaucoup des transports mais
dans l'ensemble des catégories de
salariés du pays que dans le public
comme dans le privé
encore une fois lors de cette journée
toutes les professions étaient dans la
rue infirmier avocats professeurs aux
quatre coins du pays la chanson est la
même
le président doit renoncer à la réforme
bâle la lutte va continuer jusqu'à la
fin nous irons jusqu'au conseil
constitutionnel au conseil d'état on ne
contestera le régime dont la lutte va
continuer c'est comme le break sida le
bras qui est aujourd'hui il est pas
terminée il ya toujours une lutte ça va
encore durer des années
le 24 janvier a donc été une journée de
mobilisation dans le calme et la bonne
humeur et l'absence de violences
notamment policières a détendu les
manifestants certains ont même
revendiquer leur mécontentement en
musique
[Musique]